preparations in Moscow ahead of Victory
Day on Tuesday commemorating Soviet
sacrifice in the second world war
security is a high concern after the
Drone attack on the Kremlin this month
Moscow called it a Ukrainian attempt to
assassinate Vladimir Putin Kiev denies
any involvement the important holiday
was likely leverage for Wagner group
boss yevgeni pragosian
on Friday he posted a gruesome video of
the bodies of his mercenaries
threatening to withdraw Wagner from the
contested Ukrainian city of Bak moot
unless Moscow supplies more arms Manny
called it an empty threat and so it has
proved
now says he's gotten those guarantees
his state his statements that he cares
about his troops and that's that's
basically not true this Canadian analyst
of Kremlin politics says it can be
difficult to know pregosian's true
motivations and just how great the rift
is with the Kremlin the more
intelligence resources are dedicated to
Goshen and his theatrics and drama with
the Russian Ministry of Defense shoigu
uh the less we're talking about other no
factors of what is going on further west
on the front lines there's a sense of
panic in areas near Europe's largest
nuclear power plant in southern Ukraine
Russia is now evacuating towns in the
region ahead of an anticipated Ukrainian
counter-offensive the un's atomic energy
agency boss says he is extremely
concerned about the situation adding
that all sides must act now to prevent
the threat of a severe nuclear accident
experts say multiple backup systems make
it unlike that damage to the site would
cause a meltdown but if it does happen
it could affect a 20 to 40 kilometer
radius Redmond Shannon Global News
London